senator Clinton I think it's dangerous
to have government mandates that all
Americans are required to have health
insurance I think it's very dangerous
because of the impact it will have on
the highest quality health care in
America I think that by far the most
dangerous is that espoused by all the
Democrat candidates and congressman Ron
Paul that we set a date for withdrawal
from Iraq I believe that that's a date
for surrender I believe if we do it and
there will be chaos and genocide in the
region and we will be back so when they
say we have to set a date for immediate
withdrawal in my view that it should be
dictated by events on the ground not by
an artificial deadlines and I finally
might add if the Democrats are going to
run the war in Iraq and it's anything
like the way they're running Congress
we're in deep trouble
Oh
you